also it's very important to mention he never stops like on sunday that event was over we
were like having breakfast he sits on the table and starts thinking about a bug that he believes
he just found with with one of the googlers sam and sam is like dude please chill everyone is like
chill man just best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
all right hackers we all know the value of good misconfiguration right that's often how we're
popping bugs and bug bounties well unfortunately threat locker also knows about it which is why
they built dac defense against configurations dac scans all of the enterprise machines in your
network for misconfigurations ranks them by severity and then shows them in nice graphics in a portal
it even emails your team weekly with updates so nothing slip through the cracks and the best part
about dac in my opinion is that it actually maps all these misconfigurations onto security frameworks
and it also shows you how to fix them that way when you need ammo with leadership or with it you can
point to real specific compliance gaps and get actionable steps anyway check out that locker dac
it's an awesome way to stay ahead of these issues that we as attackers love all right let's go back to
the show hey what's up so this week in bug bounty we've only got one thing to highlight but i did want
to share because it's pretty awesome um you know my heart is near and dear to ai and my heart is near and
dear to our boy justin so you all will like this one basically there is a little uh talk slash webinar
from hacker one called securing the age of ai autonomy priorities for 2026 and it's kind of like
uh continuation of the really awesome report they put out called rise of the bionic hacker which you
have if you haven't seen it has some incredible stats around like how hackers are using ai how many
like what percentage of hackers are kind of like leveling up with it what percent of companies are paying out
bounties for ai it's a really awesome report but this specifically is for the webinar which when this
goes live might have already happened but if you register here you'll go ahead and get a link to
re-watch it and they're going to be interviewing people like justin luke even james kellell from port
swigger labs so it's going to be an incredible webinar and you should definitely tune into it
what's up guys welcome back to the critical thinking bug bounty podcast we've got some incredible guests
today kieran has been here before but this is our boys bus factors first time and so uh before i do
intros we'll have him tell us about a cool bug damn already that's how we started okay yeah you got to
jump straight into it straight into the deep end okay so um guys i have this very complex uh yeah quite
complex client side heavy exploit chain because yeah you know that's me so it's client side stuff
um so i have this huge company questions about that so we'll come back to that okay okay yeah we're
gonna do that but um yeah we got this huge company and they have this support chat and they they are not
using intercom or whatever they have it in-house built and i'm like okay that is not smart because that's
more expensive than building it but okay let's take a look at that and with some match and replaces rules
i find out that the agent he can access the customer not opposite like the customer cannot
access the agent and i'm like okay how can i leverage this without agent credentials and i'm very proud of
this one because it was like everything you learn on the client side world i'm gonna use it right now
because i start checking that and it has no origin checks on the post message it uses post message for
setting up the chat but it's also not vulnerable like at the first look i'm like digging through the
minify javascript which i love it's like it makes me good it's like jumping you guys though it pumps your
blood and i'm looking into it i'm digging through the javascript and i find nothing it's been like
four days i'm fighting oh my goodness there's no origin check i'm like i cannot believe it
that is like stupid but then one day i wake up i open the jazz on a random point and i see that
there is this very stupid thing they are doing which is a json.parse and object.assign one after
the other and if you don't know that that's like textbook prototype pollution it's one of the ways to get
that and i'm like okay how can i reach it and after i feel like hours doing a lot of tests i find out
that there is a very on one of the post messages there is a very very deep config property that you can
control and there is a if check a condition if it is a string it's going to do the json.parse and the
object that assign that's why no automation was finding it because that it was inside a branch of
the code and i'm like okay let's do it and i start doing a lot of tests i cannot do much i can do the
prototype pollution or prototype poison whatever you call it but i don't get anything and then i find this
weird location whatever that is version number in it in this config i change it and it actually changes
the host that it's using to connect the web socket the web socket of the of the chat so instead of going
to i don't know chat.company.com slash web socket i can control it to go to my server and then i can
control the messages all the response yeah everything i set up this crazy malicious server that was very hard
to do because i used i had to use everything they were using like i think it was like socket js and
like that a weird library and i get it working i do a lot of post messages stuff set up connected and i get
the xss and that's like almost the end that's like one week just on that one week and then i'm very close but
the xss has no impact yet because i do a window.open i open the support chat domain whatever that is
it's not inside an iframe just to pay just a page and i start testing it and i see there's no impact
because it actually needs to connect to the real host to get some real data like pii whatever the
authentication token so i have to use another technique which is the iframe sandwich and then i
like i complete the chain with post message to prototype pollution to iframe sandwich because i do
a window.open open the support chat pop the xss open the product page that has the support chat and
make them communicate on the same origin and i get a session takeover because i can get the authentication
token and that's like a bug i'm very proud of because they used it in every page they had on
every product so it was like yeah it was scope changed it became a critical and they gave me a 50
bonus because they were like that's that's crazy like they were like since you have no social life
and you've been doing that for like yeah exactly that's what i'm gonna ask is this like an anchor
program or a live hacking target like how are you able to devote so many hours to this
i don't know what happened it's like just normal hunting normal day i became like full-time bug about
hunter for three weeks now and it was like you know what i want to pop this and it was not the best um
risk management ever you're right because it's like you would have ran into a wall and not been
able to exploit it and it would have been so much sunk time right yeah but the bounty they paid was like
amazing that paid for a few months so that that's all right you know that's amazing dude sweet well
thank you for the incredible bug uh yeah that chain is absurd and i can't believe you had to set up your
own custom web socket poc server to even get it going but uh yeah this is the stuff i think that um
you know in the critical thinking discord you are now known for so yeah if anyone doesn't know vtor he
goes by bus factor and um he's been hanging out in the critical thinking bug bounty discord for a long
time i called him and some of the other guys the front end mafia so if you ever heard me say that the
bus factor is a part of the uh the front end mafia but he's been buck hunting for about a year and a half
is that right total before you went full-time yeah total that's it but your first bounty was almost
exactly a year ago a year and two months kind of yeah cool yeah and then as of three months ago vitor
went full-time uh which is absurd at how successful he's been in such a short amount of time but
um you know i think it's just goes to speak to his you know his quality he also leads hack alongs
in the discord and so you know if people are in the discord i'm sure they've seen him lead those
hack alongs and if not you got to get in there basically he and some of his buddies were jumping
in on justin's hack alongs and often converting tons of bugs and justin's like no you guys have
to do this you have to do it do it for us as well so anyways yeah so i just would love to hear more
about your background like why you know how did you hear about bug bounty what kind of got you
interested in initially i don't actually remember how i got into bug about it the first time i was
like oh this is bug bounty and then you start reading about it i don't remember like i have no
idea the only thing i know is that a few years like maybe five years ago the first time i i tried
it like i i created an account on hack one i just wanted money i was like i need some extra cash this
this is going to be easy um it turns turns out it is not and it was quite frustrating so i tried it
for like a week or two i was like okay no that that requires a decent amount on investment and then i was
like okay i'm gonna do it later and it took like four years to try it again but i have no idea how i
started it but i was like a developer and after being a developer i became sre which is a google thing
right software reliability engineer it's kind of i don't want to say that it was a mix of devops and sre
uh if i if google people hear me saying that sre is devops they're gonna kill me and i'm not gonna get
invited to another bug squad like never again but yeah that that's what i was doing that that's my
background cool yeah i was gonna say um it was very similar for me i actually made an account hacker one
and then didn't come back to it for years later um you know i've been doing it for more like five or six
years at this point but i made my account like eight years ago but it was the same as you right
like i got on there and then just hopped off and then came back to it later yeah um yeah well one one
thing i think that uh kieran wanted to ask you on this call which we'll get to the we'll get to uh
why kieran's on the call actually i'll mention it now basically kieran and buzz factor were
a dynamic duo in the most recent google life hacking event in mexico and did incredible
and so we've got them both on here to talk about that in a second but he uh kieran actually put in
the doc here why are you called buzz factor i'm also curious it's funny that he could have asked the
person so could you you know in vegas but you guys didn't you wait you waited for this moment that's
exactly right of course it's it's a bit of a disappointing answer you know because if you don't know the
buzz factor is actually a measurement of the risk you get from keeping information and internal knowledge
from being shared among members in the company so think about it if you report a bug right now
to i don't know let's say google and two months ago you're gonna test it it is fixed plus two months
you test again and it is there they have a regression so why most of the times is because
they are not sharing knowledge internally and they have no the developers have no idea why the security
team was like hey can you change that it's like critical they have no idea they do not share the
knowledge and that's one of the things that i think the buzz factor is very critical to companies
coming from the developer background i actually hated the silos that were created inside the companies
made a lot of issues with uh security bugs but yeah but also functional bugs like guys very stupid
stuff if you just turn your head to the guy that's by your side and say hey i'm doing this that already
avoids a lot of issues and they never do it but knowing that i was with my team in london and buses
there they come from the wrong way and i was very very very close to getting hit by one just because of
that i was looking to the right they were coming from the left and that was like very close and i was
the leader of the sra team and everyone was like if you die right now you know that's like a huge buzz
factor for us and they just started making fun of that and that's cool i was like and then when i
joined hack the box we actually use our hacker names in there like your email is not like vitor at
hack the box no it's sure it's factor at the hack the box they were like it's time for you to decide
a name i was like i can't change i can change this later right and then i put this factor you can
yeah i would change it today you know but it's too late yeah exactly once once you get a handle it
just sticks it stays with you yeah i was i started in software engineering as well and um well we never
called it the bus factor but we definitely always tried to mitigate that risk right like we would even
say things like for example if corey was hit by a bus you know you know you say things like that so
you know you can kind of like mitigate the downside of one of your like important team members getting
uh something happening to them oh some people also call it i think like a lottery something like
yeah with a lottery factor yeah that's a lottery factor yeah that's a bit more positive i think
exactly yeah um i'm going to circle back to kind of your interest in front end bugs um because i want
to jump straight to getting in kieran involved here but um yeah so uh kieran you know i think um
you have been to several google life hacking events you and i won mbh with justin and and lupin back in
the beginning part of this year and you know i think that probably led to these these uh extra invites and
everything else and you and you and bus factor did incredibly well at the google lifehacking event so
do you want to kind of i don't just talk about your all's invitation and how you all decided to collab
well i initially so i got the invite from mexico and i did like because i worked with you guys like
ronnie and justin and you before i was like okay let's see if any of the others are are uh invited and
none of you guys were going and i was like i guess i'm soloing this one and then in the like guild chat
in the critical thinking server or i think it was the guild chat or something i saw
victor saying like oh i'll be at bug swats i was like this is perfect because i know victor i've seen
him around i can just reach out to him and see if he wants to work with me thankfully he did and
it's worked out um yeah that was kind of how the collaboration came about but like i could already
trust him because i've seen him so often in the space in the critical thinking server especially so
you know from the get-go we were like working together really well i think yeah if you're not
uh familiar or if you aren't hanging out in the critical thinkers chat you got to hop in there
because vitor is like very active very willing to help and you know um you know come up with some
complex chains or even even hop on different programs or collaborate um i was gonna say
yeah so the tarts of the primary i guess kind of one of their main focuses for that event was their ai
features right
i would say yes and i also want to say no you were going to ask like things about front-end bugs right
and i was like you know what i'm going to bug swap and i'm going to do what i'm best at which is
client-side stuff and then i see kieran he's like nope that's not the best you can do if you want to
like get the bounces get the reports you got to focus on ai and i never ever touched ai before but
oh so this is like your like first foray into that thing yeah it was like first time ever and um
i saw one of the guys blacklist the french guy he's a legend right and he was like on live hacking
events you have to focus on what you know what you feel comfortable and that for me is client's side
right but kieran was like no you're not going to do that you're going to lose your time doing that
you're doing ai i was like okay he has the experience you know you're going to follow and see where it
leads us turns out it went great yeah yeah tell us how it went how many reports y'all get
so yeah we got four we actually got 16 reports 14 of them are valid the two that are not are actually
self dupes that i could have reported more and then i got to one of the googlers and i was like
do i dare that no no that's going to be a dupe and i'm like okay so yeah 14. nice that's insane and
then you all ended up winning uh second place overall and winning the you know most bugs or you
know best bugs for the ai set portion of the event correct yeah yeah we had um two show and tells
and we had the best ai vrp researchers and we had second place um so mvh was just out of reach this
time but you know we can try again well you gave me a little insider baseball there and if we need
to cut this out we can but yeah you said that you all are only really got second because someone found
just something insane right yeah yeah yeah i don't i don't think you need to cut that out as far as i
know someone did something crazy and um well a few crazy they just beat us to the to the stuff but yeah
i guess it's kind of interesting it's kind of interesting to talk about um i know you all haven't
been to a ton of um a hacker one events it does feel like um at hacker one events mvh uh well i guess
it's always whoever finds the most well no it's like the the mix of criticality collaboration and
something else but yeah it does feel like um at google events they tend to uh err on the side of
who has the most critical bug rather than has like the most reports or even the most you know um payouts
for example because i'd say across the last five or six bucks watts um it has felt like there's only been
one or two where they paid out someone who had higher volume and all the rest went to whoever had
like the most critical single bug yeah so i think um google probably operates similarly if i had to
guess that it is probably the three c's but you know but they weighed it a little differently
when they're actually thinking about it i would say right or do you think that's just a byproduct of
just like how it played out i i don't know um yeah yeah but yeah we're pretty
happy anyway with the results so yeah yeah yeah yeah cool did you all have any other uh anecdotes
or thoughts about that google live hacking event well you know whether you all recommend google or just
like cool stuff that happened or if you wanted to share a bug you could or anything yeah no like we
became we both became friends with adnan adnan khan who's uh very active on like uh he does github
action stuff uh great guy um so we went to like the on-site day in uh i i can't pronounce the name of
the place it's like the mexican aztec temple and we were like wandering around the uh the area because
the tour guides were like okay you can like wander around or whatever and we're we were just talking
with some of the other hackers and i realized one of them was adnan um and i'd read his research before
so we were like we were chatting um and then we just started comparing all of our notes and all the
the stuff we found so fair and you know where where it could go and all of this uh ideation uh and we
and we decided like okay you know let's like think about this on the way back and we're like we'll go
and get back to the bus and uh we went to the wrong meeting point oh no and so eventually so bus factor
missed the bus bus yeah so the three of us did this like walk of shame back to the actual meeting point
and just got like applauded the minute we because they were all waiting for you guys everyone's already
there oh no but after that you know we had a great time with adnan just figuring out more bugs and stuff
we reported um a bunch of stuff on site with adnan as part of our collaboration as well
so it was really interesting to have that difference in approach and and the gadgets and
stuff he piled up as well yeah yeah yeah also it's very important to mention he never stops
like on sunday that event was over we were like having breakfast he sits on the table and starts
thinking about a bug that he believes he just found with with one of the googlers sam and sam
is like dude please chill everyone's like chill man just stress and he keeps going the guy the guy is a
beast honestly that's not that's not surprising i feel like there's so many bug hunters that are that
way uh several people come to mind from other events that do the same thing honestly i feel like ronnie's
a little bit that way kieran a little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah cool sweet um well so yeah let's just jump
right back to the front end thing right i mean i'm sure that your front end expertise did play you know a factor
into some of the bugs that you found there but yeah what what drew you in i mean having only been in
bug bounty you know a year and a half and only being full-time three months like what what do you
like about front end bugs why that kind of pulled you in so for a whole year i was only hunting for
server-side stuff to be honest yeah and i quite like it i got like good criticals in there but uh at some
point i started hacking on which is an amazing program and seeing what justin was doing at the
critical thinking uh community that's very client-side heavy most of them at least the people that are
are quite active in there i started trying it more and more and then in my blog you can see that i've
found one of uh amazing bugs that was on a program but was client site and i was like oh my god that's
amazing like i found a cspt to exercise and exercise to this one didn't become account takeover and i was like
that's kind of things they find all the time that's crazy like now i understand why people don't find it
you need to lock in you need to put a huge chain and i'm like you know what i'm gonna do that on epic
games on amazon everything i started doing it and my development background comes in because it's just
basically reading minify js you know and yeah it's minified but it doesn't make it a gray box review it
makes it white box you can set debugger breakpoints and things like that and i feel like i feel home when
doing that it's just easy for me and it's very hard to hunt for server-side stuff right now when i start
trying i immediately like my head starts pointing me towards javascript and stuff i'm like oh my god
i i feel like i'm stuck in here with this or is it stuck in here with me i don't know but that that's
it i just think the white box reveal part of it is nice i love it i like to understand what is happening
there yeah it feels like i think a lot of like server-side stuff is almost like um painting for
gold you know you're like you're trying to like you're you're kind of like punching in the dark you
know you're you're fuzzing you're trying a whole bunch of like weird payloads that might or might not
work you don't know you don't always get verbose errors from like looking for um like path reversals or
secondary context you know you don't know that they're there you're just like looking for them
whereas yeah i think with client side like you said it's more code review you have a lot of like
breadcrumbs you have a whole bunch of clues and a whole bunch of gadgets and you're kind of like
assembling a puzzle rather than like you know you know kind of like uh shooting in the dark
yeah like from a problem-solving standpoint i think client-side is a lot more satisfying when you
you pop a big chain um which isn't you know financially server-side is probably better on average
but client-side is more fun i have to say yeah i do think client-side often has slightly more user
interaction doesn't it like you know you often need like one click or you need like um some sort
of water yeah it's kind of hard to affect many users at once like even with good post message chains
you're usually still hitting like a single user even for ato so yeah you're like a step down in
severity it's hard to get crits you get highs most of the time yeah yeah luckily i think a lot of
programs kind of respect the hustle these days right you know they uh they understand the difficulty
with it and they're willing to kind of bump it up especially the mature ones that people like you
will kind of target or hack on specifically yeah yeah like there are definitely programs that treat
them as good as server-side which is really really nice but yeah during the event um vitor was like
getting distracted with some of the non-ai stuff and i was like like do you remember in uh i think it
was vegas where we got we went down this rabbit hole of something and
then justin kind of turned around and he was oh yeah guys there is bonuses it is like 100 bonus or
something that can wait till after the event focus on the task yes so i you heard you heard the
ghost of justin the the ghost of obi-worn justin in your ear saying focus on the event
so i like channeled this ghost of justin into getting vitor away from like the rabbit hole and
on to like like dude we've got bonuses to go for let's keep on track um and it was the right move
in retrospect like it paid off really well to do that yeah he did that for us in tokyo too if you
remember at the table he basically like always helped us like re-prioritize and that probably is a
really underrated perspective of full-time hunting you know it was like just that ability to prioritize
no absolutely um it's a it's a core skill for bug bounty really that no one really talks about
yeah we've mentioned it a few times but it's like there's not a lot of resources out there and it's
honestly hard to build it's like um it's a mental model that you have to build for yourself because
it really does vary depending on your skill set and some people have a lot of success jumping around and
some people have a lot of success going really deep you know and so even though i think there are often
optimal decisions like the ones you're talking about if you all had focused on the ass stuff and
found no bugs maybe it'd been better for vitor to have like found two client side mediums or something
you know like you can never you can never know what the counterfactual is but obviously it clearly
paid off for you guys because you did really well and i think knowing the target knowing from before
what google accept and what they look for that helps to educate that decision as well yeah
sweet dude yeah vitor what do you think has been kind of like the biggest challenge of going full-time
over these last couple well one let me just reflect on the fact that it's absolutely ridiculous that he's
been the success this successful in only three months of of doing bug hunting he like he literally was
teaching the class in the critical thinking server within like a month of being a full-time hunter but
anyways yeah what's what's been the hard part or what's been difficult for you
so before becoming full-time i actually did plan for that for like six months i had like an a b c d e f you
know i was like i'm fine i have the savings i have everything i need and then i jump into it and you may
know that i have justin as my mentor right and justin is like man you have to lock in in one program
only one program do at least a hundred hours in it before jumping around and that's dude that's very
hard because it's so easy to get frustrated and i have this thing that i get frustrated even easier
because of adhd which is something that a lot of people has and i was not medicated by that time now
i am again like uh which is way better but at the same time you have to be careful and now i can lock
in more but not jumping around like program to program and getting that dopamine rush every time
you start a new program and start finding low hanging fruits and things like that that is so hard so
locking in one program like not not one program to be honest one app sometimes one feature for hours is
very hard but at the same time it pays off so well like that's amazing the other things that were like
unexpected they were not really unexpected like you report the bounty the company sometimes takes
like three months to pay things happen on the program side on the hunter side that's like
it is unexpected you now it is expected plans but you don't want it and you get frustrated it's not
nice you need to handle that somehow but that's on the plans that's big bouncy yeah that's so that's one
thing i was going to break up bring up is i think a lot of people right now with ai and also just the
fact that bug bounty is now like you know eight or ten years old are probably scared to jump in i think
a lot of people have that fear that it's like they're going to try to do bug bounty and then there's going
to be no bugs left or no money left or anything like that what would you say to people who are like
you know considering it like do you still think it's a good decision that sort of thing
well uh it's like people saying the world will end tomorrow next year whatever you're going to have
it every year every like people love it people people love the chaos guys that's the news that spread
if you say no bug bounty will be good we're gonna get some good money for years and what i want to hear
about it they want they want the the chaotic news you know which is it's a lie come on the thing is you
need to adapt ai is coming you need to adapt to that maybe find ai bugs uh put ai into your workflow
it doesn't need to be fully automated it's kind of thing but it's going to be there now if i do recommend
it or not there are a lot of things you need to think about before doing that right like where do you
live is that in the us or is that like me living in brazil which if you make like two two thousand
dollars a month you have a good salary for brazil you know if you do like two a month in the us dude
that's not good i'm sorry for you you know so there are a lot of things to consider i would say like
do some research critical thinking justin made that uh full-time guide right yeah yeah it's been
huge right it's helped a lot of people i think um and i think kind of like that whole like 100k in a
year if i had to do it all again thread he posted that just keeps doing rounds when people reshare it
i think that's motivated a lot of people too but i have one thing to say about it guys
jesting has the superpower he can lock in for hours and hours and do it over and over again be realistic
with yourself yeah okay yeah no i'm the same way i think that i'm actually uh undiagnosed adhd and i
you know i'm actually i'll maybe i'll talk to you offline about like what your experience was like
kind of pre-medication and and having been medicated because yeah i've never taken any medicine
um and clearly i do fine but i do wonder what it's like to lock in like that because it's a huge struggle
for me as well um cool sweet uh well i'm glad we got the chance to talk about that i know we had
that listed um yeah let's go ahead and jump straight over to the full-time bug bounty section
here i think one we were already talking about it but two it's something that you know i jumped
in full-time in january and kieran you did at the same time it was about last year
um last april or something last april cool yeah so i think you know i think there are lots of
thoughts around that um just listening to what vtor said what kind of jumped out to you kieran about
like you know what are your thoughts on full-time bug bounty uh i i think i almost always recommend
keeping bug bounty as a hobby for most people because it is so many ups and downs like if you don't get
paid well in a particular month because you focused on the wrong program like it's it's mentally very
difficult um so i think keeping it as a hobby for as long as possible is wise but for the people who
want that extra bit of freedom in their life to do like whatever they want um it is just amazing and i
wouldn't trade the freedom for anything like there's no way i'll ever go back if i can help it um yeah
that's my two cents on that yeah yeah i agree i do think like um i will say the people that listen to
this pod probably are in that like upper 10 or 5 of you know hackers because they're like consuming all
the bug bounty content that is across every platform um so for them it might make more sense
but i think yeah you're right for the vast majority of people it's like a perfect side hustle because you
can do as little or as much as you want all the time and it's just like extra money if it works out
and if it doesn't work out you just learn some skills and build your resume and who cares right
like there's kind of like no downside to doing it when you have a full-time job as like hobby time
but the downside to doing it when you don't have a job is that if you don't make any money you don't
get it you know you aren't you aren't providing so um yeah and yeah like i have friends who call it
like um beer money but it's like they're quite successful bug bounty hunters it's like what kind
of beer are you drinking to call it beer money right it's more like champagne money or something
yeah i always hear that phrase champagne problems for people who complain about something that like
is like actually good or whatever um cool let's do a round let's do a round robin of all three of us
with like what your hacking routine is because i think we're in three very different parts of the
world um you know being the the us and the eu and then brazil um i'm curious what your all's kind
of like hacking routines are like and and specifically maybe mention like how much you hack per week
and then you know maybe if you want to mention hours or whatever i just think that'd be interesting
for the audience all right uh i can start with that that i try to keep as much as possible of a fixed
routine not change it a lot because i think your body gets used to like think well the same amount same
time every day so i usually do that start like 9 a.m sometimes 10 it depends like there is a non-negotiable
i need some kind of exercise every day like either hitting the gym or i fight bgj which is amazing
get your body your body very tired and then you go do some mental stuff you know like working so like
9 10 i started and i try to do pomodoro sessions because they are amazing for just keeping you focused
and sometimes you want to like distract yourself thinking about something else and then you look at
the timer and you're like nah i can't do that in 10 minutes in 10 minutes i'm gonna have a break let's
let's lock in so that's what i've been doing and also setting micro tasks like things that i need to
do all the time things that i need to find out so i just do that every day from like 9 10 to 4 5 at most
some days let's be honest some days i do it for like 30 minutes i get tired and i go watch netflix
and but that's that's why i do it full-time that's why i do bug about full-time that's the freedom i'm
talking about if i need to go take my dog on a walk on any time of the day i can things like that
but my routine is it's basically that cool maybe like you go ahead kieran yeah i have a question for
victor actually which is like how often do you really stick to that routine like you know i also
try and kind of keep keep a i don't do pomodoros but i do have i have like a morning session until
lunchtime and so on but i find it really hard to stick to it if that makes sense like that's the ideal
for me but do you succeed in sticking to that routine yeah during the morning and on mondays
it's a bit harder but the thing that i found out is that if on mondays instead of hacking i do something
like for example today we uh defcon dropped a lot of talks and videos on youtube that's what i'm going
to do for the monday because that's inspiration reading blog posts that people have been releasing
during the weekend or last week things like that so on mondays i do that since it's a hard day instead
of fighting back against it i kind of accept and adapt i think that's way better for someone that
has like adhd stuff and if if it is not working i'm like i need to work and it's not working dude
go i don't know go to the gym do something go for a walk whatever but don't keep fighting the only
thing you're going to get is next day you're going to wake up frustrated tired you're not going to be
able to hack and that's something that is not very possible if you are working for huge companies and
things like that so if we can do that being full-time hunters why not you know why not use the freedom
why not use the idea of working less if that's what we really want so that that's basically what i do
nice yeah kieran what about you uh yeah i have like at the moment i'm jet lagged because of the
mexico like i'm still jet lagged i have not recovered from from the the jet lag yet but mostly i have like
a morning session if i'm awake in the morning i work to lunch work into the afternoon and then
i work from the we work in edinburgh so i'll get home before dinner and make my dinner or whatever
but i i don't use um i keep a checklist of like my top priorities for the day
and i try and knock them out in order of there it's in order of priority so i knock them out one by one
uh sometimes i get none of them done sometimes i get all of them done i also really go with the flow
most of the time um sometimes there's stuff i really don't want to do and you can't just go with
the flow to ignore it so you have to kind of force yourself but yeah i definitely echo vitor's sentiments
that you need to use the freedom you have when you're doing full-time bug bounty because like
otherwise why would you do it you're just doing a nine-to-five makes no sense um so yeah pretty similar
sweet yeah and in fact isn't there a series called day in the life of a hacker or something that you're
working with getting published or something well yeah um but crowd should have that out this month
sometime okay sweet blog posts on that yes so we'll have more on that from you and also for me but um
yeah for me it's like i definitely am like kind of treating it more like a full-time job this first
year to make sure that it's like ironed out and i'm providing enough for my family of five over here
but it is really nice like you said to be able to just be interrupted and not care right if i have
like kids appointments or kids that run in here or you know need to need to get out or like like you
said vtor go on a run or go lift weights in the gym um it's really nice to not have to care or think or
tell anyone that you're going to go do that right um yeah for my schedule i try to work like 8 to 4 30.
um but you know lots and lots of interruptions with kids lots of appointments lots of sports lots of
taking off early to go take care of them so sweet um and then yeah so the last section that we really
wanted to cover here was um well actually any any closing thoughts on full-time bug bounty
yeah go ahead go ahead yeah okay so go ahead kieran then i go okay sure i think anyone on the fence about
it should just go for it like if it's eating away at your mind like oh should i go full-time you brought
that won't go away that thought's always going to be there so just jump into it dive off the deep end
give it a shot yeah i will say for the people that are considering it they probably know they're good
enough to do it and and they might struggle to take that leap at least it was for me every time i would
go to leave my employer would like give me a raise or give me a promotion or whatever and so i do think
if you're going to do it set yourself a hard date like assuming you have the money saved up for the
runway and all that set yourself a hard day and like don't let anyone talk you out of it because
it's so easy to be talked out of it just out of fear or out of like another opportunity yeah and
i'm meeting uh you know green jam he's at the google events sometimes yeah he's coming to edinburgh
tomorrow so i'll be getting dinner or whatever with him i want to ask him about his full-time
experience because he's just gone full-time very well he did when when did he start so
oh uh i mean i think it's been like a month or something since he's gone full-time but
you know it's been a few years since he's doing part-time bug bounty so yeah really looking
forward to hearing what he's what his experience is so far yeah that's awesome
yeah i was going to say that doing full-time hunting or doing any kind of remote kind of work
guys be careful if uh social connections you know do not like isolate yourself and forget to keep making
friends and things like that because we are all humans don't run away from that and when thinking
about making bug bounty a full-time thing or not you're gonna slowly stop treating it as a hobby
to be honest if you're making money is it really a hobby like you're making money that's paying the
beers or the bills so i was already picking the bills instead of the beers you know it was not a hobby
anymore by the end that was a lie i was telling myself to i don't know why so be careful with that
yeah that last thing is super true i definitely when i was working a full-time job and doing bug
bounty on the side i kind of like felt like it was like a game and so i would like justify doing it all
the time in the evenings and my wife is like no it's work you're just doing work i'm like yeah i
know but i love it she's like yeah but you're just working two jobs like you're working all day and
then you're working all night like you know like uh as far as like impact on family impact on your life
like you're just doing two jobs and i was like yeah but it's so fun so anyways i made it the main
thing so that i didn't have to work two jobs you know i think that a lot of people probably that
probably resonates with a lot of people i think i've gone full circle there i'm doing pen tests to pay the
bills at the base level now it's back to being a hobby for me especially with the life hacking events
at this point listen you've doubled what you expected this year kieran so just everyone can
root on kieran and celebrate him as well you've doubled your goal this year as a full-time hunter
you've definitely given yourself the leeway to not have to like do pen tests for your your bills
especially after this google event come on before that i understand but after the google event no
complaining all right yeah so um one thing you know i think that's interesting i think uh kieran you may
have put put this in the document but um actually let's just ask vitor this is your first time ever
doing google uh sorry first time doing ai related bugs um you probably had a lot of the thoughts that
me and kieran have had over the last year or two with like hey these bugs are kind of weird they're
sometimes like higher user interaction they're either usually targeting one user so they're kind of similar to
client side bugs but they're often a little bit social engineering e and they're also kind of weird
because they're non-deterministic sometimes you're like trial multiple times that did like just give
me your thoughts on like ai kind of vr like ai hacking in general um having really kind of dove in so
recently for your first time okay um it was a weird feeling when i popped the first bug ai bug by myself
because we and monkey we were like covering each other like he was burning out and i was like okay so
you chill now today's your day off he had i don't know anything to do and i was like i'm going to do some
hacking and today i popped it by myself after learning a lot from kieran i was like okay that is weird
it feels like if i report this to the company i'm scamming then i don't know right it doesn't feel like that
yeah it doesn't feel like a real bug that's gonna happen 100 of the time sometimes the prompt injection
fails things happen i don't know i still wrapping my head around it yes but i i got this very
interesting question on twitter a guy asked like should i learn ai hacking or web hacking and i'm like
dude it's a mix of both there's they do not exist without each other most of the exfiltrations
we did used a lot of decent good old client-side hacking like images things like that to exfiltrate
information if you don't learn that you're not going to get there delivery also use the same things
a lot of times before the event i was like what is ai hacking i don't know making ai on a company page
say something racist or anything like that like prompt injection i had no idea it could be actually so
impactful like leaking someone a company's data or someone's emails and things like that and at least
google cares a lot about that i don't know how other companies uh deal with all this this kind of
stuff i've seen a few reports on mostly on the hacker one and the companies are like we don't care that
much you're gonna pay as a medium at most high google no google is like critical critical don't if you
can actually excretrate anything that's a critical and it's crazy you know i don't know how i'm gonna deal
with ai hacks on other programs we have another live hacking events in like two weeks three weeks and i'm
going to focus on ai stuff because because whatever that's what i want to do and i want to see what's
going to happen like i want to see how the company is going to deal with that so yeah that's the point
i am right now yeah yeah that's why i wanted to ask you because i think it does feel kind of weird it feels a
little bit different like you said uh partially because of the yeah it feels like it's not that
likely to be exploited but it is really nice that there are companies at least like google that do take
it seriously especially when it can control your iot devices you know like uh when there are really
weird things like that going on and so uh and so yeah yes we yeah nice yeah this is the uh google cam
that i bought to do some testing but yeah it's uh we may have made a run for a smart lock in tokyo
like there's all kinds of things you could potentially imagine
man i think we're still like a i think we're at a very simple level of complexity for a lot of
these systems like we'll begin to see a lot more like server-side issues maybe mcp specific issues
or maybe it won't be mcp whatever it'll be and similarly client-side issues coming out of the
the systems built on llms um in the next like year or two as things get a lot more you know the
infrastructure and all the libraries get a lot more complex as well um so right now it feels kind
of scammy because it's like oh what's the exploitability but the minute you can do some
real like pass traversal stuff through tool calls i think it'll get really interesting yeah and i mean
in that episode where me and justin interviewed um one of the google staff you know they were talking
just about how at their scale when there's billions of users it's like this is probably going
to get exploited at some point right and so it makes sense for them to take it seriously i think
yeah yeah it does cool yeah did you all have a or you go ahead vitor yeah i just want to say that
you also have to think about the non-ai related stuff that is happening around ai like think about
i don't know let's put it gemini gemini is getting huge and they have to build features around it
like non-ai related like having gems sharing gems creating chats sharing chats things like that so
we have this ai gold rush everyone want to become the best most sold ai product guys that's amazing
that means developers making mistakes for a bug bounty hunter like that is not amazing but it is amazing
you guys get right it's good for hackers yeah yeah you're right they do have to move fast right they
feel this really strong pressure to move fast and so not only do they want to incentivize bug hunters to look
at them i think that's why google's paying well i think there's that's why there's like really good ai
safety payouts like i mentioned on a previous podcast with both anthropic and open ai willing to pay you
know 25 or 35 000 for jail breaks and i think it's because they really want our they want our expertise and
our attention and they want it right now because they have to release next week so they can't wait and so
they have to put a really heavy incentive on our time and so i think that you're right vitor i think
that's like very um very cool for us right yeah like google have updated their ai vrp very recently
so that's just a sign that things are moving forward um and they're restructuring they restructured some
of like what a p1 is and what a p2 is and stuff in the new the new system yeah exactly so if anyone
yeah so if anyone's been confused about why um when vitor was saying like it was like critical
critical critical it's because of the the um attributes of their report and with their new
reporting framework it's like very clear so if people are confused or curious about how that's
all set up you can go to google's we might drop it in the show notes but google basically has a new
like ai vrp table on their rewards and it explains exactly what would make it an s1 or what would make it
a p1 or a p2 etc and so you can just go in there and see exactly what the impact and would be and what
the payout would be depending on what bug you're looking for so um sweet did we have any other thoughts
on ai vrps that you all did not get to say yet
cool um sweet sweet sweet i think the only other thing that i had for
um the pod was this is more of a little bit of just like fun it's actually you know we'll save that
we'll save that for um we'll do like a news episode we'll make this just like a full blown
guest episode and we'll do news next time um where can people follow you or find you i know you
mentioned your blog vitor go ahead and tell us spell that out for them so they can find your blog
yeah so it's uh okay that's gonna be hard because it's my my name is vitor falcon dot com that's where
i've been posting more and more stuff uh because it was i bet i i i forgot about my blog sometimes i
forget about it guys you have to do the hunting and actually if you do the hunting you find yeah
that's the point like it does but it's very uh it's a hidden it's indirect money you know the self
marketing stuff yes but uh the thing is you have to do the hunting and find cool stuff that you can
actually write about because there's no point on writing i don't know i don't know what i would write
about if i had nothing to talk about anything nice that i found during hunting or whatever i know
kieran does that he just like shares his accountability stuff every week i know you do
that jazz but but that's not my style you know so it's a bit harder for me yeah sweet yeah i'll
spell that out so his blog is at vitor v-i-t-o-r falcal f-a-l-c-a-o dot com and yeah he mentioned
his like uh full-time hunting journey from the last three months it's a really great read
sorry go ahead kieran now i was just gonna also shout out his uh first three months as a full-time
hunter blog post that he's done recently so worth checking out for sure yeah yeah and as far as uh
kieran you can find him at monkey hack on on on x but he also has monkey hacks the really nice um
newsletter so you should go subscribe to that and that's uh that's monkey dot i e m-o-n-k-e dot i e
sweet cool well thank you guys and we'll call that the pod and that's a wrap on this episode of
critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical thinking
content uh or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can hop in the
community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of master classes
hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a
great time trust me i'll see you there